there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm goes off please leave the
building in an orderly fashion through
the nearest fire
exit please use the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall or the fire
exit in the store room adjacent to the
stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance to
the building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by Council sta
please note that the meeting will be
live
streamed please switch off mobile phones
or turn them to
silent please note that the toilet and
handwashing facilities are in the foyer
area members of the public there is
drinking water available near the main
doors in the hall while you while you
can of course film or take photographs
during this meeting please note that
this should be done without disruption
to the meeting and can only be done from
the seats that have been reserved for
this purpose can I at this point please
ask therefore for you to raise your hand
clearly in the air if you wish to take
photographs or film this
evening
okay members please be upstanding to
receive the chairman councelor Jack
laurman and the chief executive Mr
Jonathan
Stevenson
please be seated
[Music]
members members you were not you were
note to that our chaplain is near at the
moment perhaps courting traffic so we're
going to continue on without if you're
all happy with it thank
you right we take item Agenda One
apologies for
absence we've received apologies from
councelor Nick Booth G and councelor
Gary Myers councelor Bob mu and
councelor Stuart Wilson are there any
other apologies
counc Bel councelor Mike Carter okay
anyone
else thank
you agenda item two minutes of the H of
the meeting held on the 31st of October
2023 members are you happy for me to
sign the minutes of the me meeting held
on the 31st of
October agreed thank
you item three to receive Declarations
of Interest are there any Declarations
of
Interest
there are none thank
you item four announcements from the
chairman leader of P Services well to
start with thanks for coming I know it's
just coming up for Christmas the first
thing I would say is that uh yes I've
had a a really busy period since our
last meeting I'm not going to go through
it them all I'm sure you're interested
but you know it be too long to go on but
I've had a very interesting period and
um first of all I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank all of you for how
you've helped me through this year I
really do want to say that seriously I'd
like to thank our officers for the
assistance and encouragement they've
given me over the last year and
um I don't know I just think that things
have gone extremely well this year I've
been on a number of different working
groups and I've been very impressed
about the input by many people
especially our officers and I'd like
particularly to say thank you to Emily y
who's been a steadfast St you know real
St St power on my side and is advised us
fully all the way through thank you so
right um
so that's my me done so canel John Mas
do you wish to make any
statements chairman all I'd like to do
is Echo your sentiments about the the
time of the year and wish everyone a
much earlier Merry Christmas than uh we
would ordinarily do
I hope everyone has a really great break
thank
you thank you can Mr Stevenson would you
like to say
anything thank you chairman um yes if if
possible I would be wrong to not
acknowledge um tonight is um the last
Council Mee of Sonia worington we
leaving the council obviously very soon
I think it' be good to just acknowledge
all the work she's done for R District
Council over many years so um we all
appreciate the work you've done and look
forward to hearing from you and seeing
you in the future um I'm sure you won't
not going that far but yeah a big thank
you for all the work you've done and I'm
sure other members might want to say
something as well so thank
you I won't embarrass On You by calling
for a response we'll continue on thank
you Mr ston item five businesses from
last council meeting there are no items
of business defer from the last meeting
item six minutes of the executive and
committee meetings held between the
period of the 5th of October to the 24th
of November are these noted
members thank you seven item seven
report of the Constitution working group
proposed committee structure from May
24th I will now invite councelor James
newort as chairman of the Constitution
working group to introduce this
report
thank you
chairman um so firstly um I think it's
right to thank and take the opportunity
to thank all the members of the
Constitutional working group for their
commitment and enthusiasm in which has
been an intense piece of work also I
must of course thank Emily e Sonia and
CLA Mayu for their hard work and expert
knowledge and
guidance on the 23rd of May 2023 the
Council resolved to adopt a committee
style of governance with effect from
annual council meeting in May 2024 to
support the transition to the committee
system the council also appointed a
constitutional working group with a
remit of developing a workable committee
structure and producing terms of
reference for each of the Committees
within that structure should be noted
that the Constitutional working group
was also tasked with supporting the
monitoring officer with a full review of
the council's Constitution the revised
Constitution will be presented to
council for adoption in February
2024 I won't go over the contents of the
report but will just highlight a few of
the key points in discussing the
structure for the new committee system
the Constitutional working group has
taken many aspects of governance into
consideration including the legal
requirements Rochford District council's
previous committee structure Sia's
nearest neighbor comparisons the size of
the council the use of subcommittees
working groups and panels for specific
pieces of
work in the new um proposed committee
structure there will be 10 committees
with four
subcommittees all members have received
a briefing on the proposed new committee
system with an opportunity to be for
feedback to be addressed and members of
the Constitutional working group have
been actively advised feedback during
this
process this is very much a starting
point and that we would expect a review
of how the new structure works in around
12 months
time there is a proposal of 57 meetings
in the new structure in comparison with
the current
61 counselor allowances will be
considered once we receive the report
from the Independent renumeration
panel in in conclusion The Proposal in
front of you tonight will prepare
Council for the change in governance for
annual Council in May
2024 chairman therefore I would like to
move that recommendations R1 R2 and R3
on page 7.2 of the report are approved
by council tonight
please gooun m
m
thank you chair I would like to second
that uh proposal and I'd like to reserve
the right to speak to later thank you
thank you members there are three
recommendations set on in this report I
can
stepto thank you chairman I if I may I'd
like some points of
clarification um committee
system uh means that each
committee can only debate and make
recommendation to the full Council so
the first point of clarification is why
do we need committee meetings when it's
going to come to full Council anyway it
seems a little bit crazy to me that
we're going to end up debating the same
thing
[Music]
twice with regards to the chairman of
the committee uh committees
they themselves do not have any
executive
powers so the question I would ask at
this point for
clarification is what role does the
leader and Deputy leader positions hold
within the
structure in my mind they become
Superfluous and why do we need a leader
a deputy
[Music]
leader and with regards to the
development and the licensing committees
when you look at the flow chart that's
been
provided it actually says that they have
then to report to full
Council how does that work when both of
those committees are semi
judicial I don't quite understand how
that's going to be the
case and also as well with regards to
emergency
situations and to give you an example
chairman some years ago when we had some
very bad flooding as portfolio hold at
the time I was enabled
to take some action and provide those
poor people that were flooded out with
the necessary skip so they could get rid
of all the stuff that was damaged and
also that we stopped charging them rates
whilst they were unable to live in their
property
when that situation occurs do we have to
go to a committee to get that decision
and then back to full Council or how is
the emergency Powers going to work where
does the where does they fit into the
structure because doesn't often happen
but we know it does happen thank you
[Music]
chairman okay so n do you want to answer
those questions
[Music]
first thank you um chairman and thank
you councelor stepto for your um
questions some of these items that um
some of these points specific points
that you raise will be taken into
consideration under when we're um under
the review of The Constitution and
delegated powers and as yet we have not
got to that point so you're asking about
um chairman emergency Powers
um so those that will be addressed
through the review of The Constitution
at that stage so at the moment we're
we're simply proposing the
structure if I can ask Emily to address
the other points that you raised um and
I could answer you about the leader and
the deputy leader
now but I'm not really sure because
whether I should address at this stage
as we do have a public question on
notice on that same issue so would you
prefer that I wait till then to address
it or would you like that answer
now i' like the answer now please
chairman sorry I would like the answer
now um one of the points that I didn't
mention was that if we can um save the
the the money that the leader and the
deputy leader cost us uh we'd have quite
a sum of money to be using on other
project well members as per advice uh we
have got a public uh question on notice
um would you like that brought for
forward at this time to marry up with
what the what council of stepto is
saying so we can address it all in one
go can I therefore ask that that
question I think it's councel chur your
way of um well of this c m Mr your
way thank you chair and thank you for
let me go forward now I know it's keeps
it in keeping with the whole order of
business so my question is to the lead
member for governance Communications the
new joint Administration are bringing in
a much more democratic system of
governance a committee system this will
remove what I consider the undemocratic
cabinet stroke executive system that
gives power to one political party to
push through their agenda without
consideration or debate however I did
note that the proposed system still has
a leader and Deputy leader so could you
please explain what the role is within
the new committee system in terms of
what power they will hold for example
can they rule over or veto for Council
decisions and can they make decisions
outside of committee meetings thank you
very much chairman thank
M
C thank you
chairman um right thank you for your
question Miss way um members of the
Constitutional working group are
currently working on drafting the new
constitution to bring to full Council in
February 2024 to reject to reflect the
change in governance from an executive
model to committee system the defined
leader and Deputy leader roles will be
formalized at this stage broadly
speaking though the role of the leader
is very much paired back in a committee
system as they do not have any executive
powers the leader role is generally to
represent the council externally in
terms of policy position as directed by
the council opposed to the chairman who
has a Civic and ceremonial
role the leader will provide leadership
to counselors for example coordinating
cross-party discussions committee places
being an
example to be the they will also be the
point of contact for officers when
seeking a political steer from the
council's
administration they will represent the
council as an as the employer of head of
paid service and take responsibility for
their annual appraisal discharge any
delegated authority given to them by
full Council for example the council
might designate them as a signatry to an
agreement or a
contract represent and pursue the
interests of the council in the
community and at international national
and Regional
levels so in summary as the council will
operate a committee system the leader
Deputy has no formal legal powers and
duties vested in him or her under the
Local Government Act
1972 or the Local Government Act
2000 however in practice all local
authorities need to appoint a leader and
each leader will hold the most
significant elected member role within
the council the council's leader will be
the political elected head the focus for
policy Direction and Community
Development and the chief Advocate and
Ambassador for the
district coming on to the deputy leader
the deputy leader role is simply to
deputize in the leader's
absence thank you chairman counc stto
does that answer your
questions that ask that particular Point
chairman but uh there are a number of
others that I did raise particularly
around the
Committees thank thank you chairman and
good evening members um I'll take the
other questions posed by councelor
stepto um so it's not accurate to say
that committees can only make
recommendations committees can be given
delegated authority by the full Council
to make decisions on certain matters
that fall within their terms of
reference but that all stems from the
power vested into those committees by
the full Council and that will be set
out in the revised Constitution that's
coming before this Council in February
in the under the scheme of delegations
section um that kind of links into the
question around the development
committee and the Licensing and
Regulatory Committee in both cases as is
the case now actually those committees
are appointed by the full Council and
they are given delegated authority by
the full Council to make full and final
decisions in relation to those uh
regulatory
matters uh with regards to the emergency
decision Provisions again they are at
for in the revised Constitution as as
set out uh in the current Constitution
uh and generally speaking within a
committee system the emergency functions
sit with the chief executive and then
there are Provisions in place to have uh
sort of retrospective sign off by the
full Council um but obviously the
swiftness of action is the most
important and crucial thing in those
emergency situations uh so the
delegation normally sits with the chief
executive and then there are systems of
checks and balances to make sure that
that Authority is not used unreasonably
or irresponsibly thank you
chairman well members um I think that
explained it quite in detail I think we
are talking about the structure of this
committee sorry councelor thought I
didn't see
you uh thank you chairman a couple of
points of clarification if I may to the
chairman of the Constitution working
group
on uh page
7.2 2.1 of the proposed structure it
describes the committee as environment
and climate change
committee on page
7.3 it describes it as a climate
emergency Committee in the OR chart
again describes it as environment and
climate change committee so can we
clarify which is
correct also on page 7.7 item
7.4 it says the council is required to
have the following committee by law
standards in section 53 of the Local
Government Act
2012 in the Old Chart it shows standards
as a subcommittee of the audit and
governance committee I believe that as a
subcommittee would not have
decision-making Powers even by
delegation uh the powers that required
um for a statutory committee and by law
thank
you Council nle are you in a position to
answer those
points um for clarification on I think
Council Foster was asking about the name
of the committee that's as in the terms
of reference it's the environment and
climate change
committee
um
and in terms
of um councilor Foster was asking about
the standards committee if I could just
ask Emily you'll to clarify on that
point
please thank you chairman um the uh
proposed standards
subcommittee will have the authority
delegated to it by the audit and
governance committee which in turn has
been given delegated authority by the
full Council to hear standards
complaints and to make decisions in
terms of Standards complaints so that
does satisfy the legal requirement to
have a committee or a subcommittee of
the council that is able to
independently consider standards
complaints that have been referred by
the monitoring
[Music]
officer I happy with that
guys thank you chairman could I just say
on the first point about the committee
name could I suggest that the report is
amended to have a consistent description
in all the different
elements
no members I can't see any more H oh c
Mrs
Mason thank you chair I would just like
to conclude this if I may um we have I
can
see still read this
report whilst I acknowledge that
personal preferences may wish for some
Alternatives I do believe that members
should reflect on how these
recommendations have
transpired the cross party working group
has spent countless hours reading and
understanding the implications of each
and every detail that has given to these
recommendations
surprisingly and I admit I can to be
pleasantly surprised there was no
conflict we experienced moments of
confusion and compromise but most of all
the working group has been dominated by
an attitude of constructive
cooperation the members of the working
group have been ably assisted by
officers and I would like to put on
public record my personal appreciation
for the patience and pres professional
support of the monitoring officer Emily
Yu and I'm sure that the other members
of the committee would Echo me in
expressing that
appreciation I do trust that this report
will be accepted and passed with the
cooperation that we have seen on the
working group thank
[Music]
youon thank you chairman um look the
decision was made a few months ago that
we migrate from a cabinet to a committee
system um I and the conservative group
don't see a persuasive argument um to
justify all the work um we still
question actually how the resident of
Rochford District generally will be
better off as a result but we do accept
that that ship has
sailed over time people will see the
advantages and disadvantages because
that's the way it works in any system
that you have and be able to judge for
themselves however we need to be careful
that we don't accept as a general rule
it is a much more democratic system if
one party
has an overall majority there is not
much difference between a cabinet and a
committee
system and I know of a number of
councils that have committee systems
that wish that they had a cabinet system
and vice versa so I'm quite open-minded
on
it I do look at appendix C and see that
there's many more
meetings arguably under 6.4 it's
certainly costlier and I suspect there's
a number of costs that uh we have hav
yet been able to bring out certainly
appears to be more time consuming and
has a reputation for slowing down
decision- making and that's not what I'm
saying it's what councils say that
actually have a committee system but hey
I think we go through periods of it's
time for a change we've had an executive
stroke cabinet system for a while let's
see how a committee system works so you
know let's be positive about that
turning to the report itself I do not
agree with the calendar of meetings as
currently set out in particular if I
highlight that every third Tuesday is
taken up with a full council meeting
that's an important meeting meaning that
individuals that have other engagements
meeting regularly on those days are
compromised with their other activities
the same can also be said for
development on every fourth Thursday of
each month so my suggestion is that that
calendar is Revisited to at least take
account of that even if you put six on a
Tuesday and six on a Thursday of Council
meetings that might enable people to
balance their other interests in life to
lock up every third Tuesday could be
quite demanding so thank you chairman
for letting me make those points thank
you Council
[Music]
C thank you uh Mr chairman I'd like to
ask on page 76 where it's got all the
basic allowances and everything on that
um it says the following assumptions
have been applied to the above table and
in the second bullet point it says there
will be two opposition groups based on
the current political makeup of the
council well if the makeup of the
council changes there could be five
opposition groups I therefore feel that
that bullet point should be amended um
to take up the makeup of the council
because it says there will be and
therefore that could be put putting it
into stone so therefore I feel there
should be amend on that particular point
Thank
you thank you chairman yeah just to
address that particular point on on the
allowances um it it it has been put into
the report as indicative but um until we
actually get the report back from the
Independent renumeration panel um we
won't be able to address that at this
point in time so that we do have to wait
for that report to come back as to their
recommendations and then that will come
to council for
consideration thank
you thank you members counc m
w thank you chair um just in response to
what um councelor Simon won said about
Diary keeping um I told you take on
board your point but personally having
um a set meeting on a set day each month
um much suits my diary much better and
as counselors we are expected to be
flexible with our other arrangements to
be available to attend meetings thank
you
chair M
mtion thank you chair yeah I would like
to address the point as well on the
council meetings the development
committee has C customly always met on a
Thursday so there is no actual
fundamental change there if there is
nothing on the development committee
agenda the meeting is cancelled but we
have it in our Diaries so we are aware
that should we be called on to serve on
that committee we are available it is up
to us obviously to arrange our personal
diaries with the suggestion of alternate
Tuesdays and Thursdays that would just
add to
confusion and the other reason that we
have this is because again there is
certainty there is certainty in our
Diaries we actually have less meetings
the present executive system has eight
executive meetings eight executive
briefings 16 and six I believe Council
meetings this has I believe it's 10 and
of course if there is no urgent business
or no business they will be cancelled
but the arrangements are put put in
place it is much easier to cancel a
meeting than it is to arrange one as I'm
sure we've all found out when we've
tried to arrange meetings it's difficult
but having something set is helpful
thank
you thank you can
step thank you chairman thank you for
allowing me to come back I just wanted
to clarify a particular Point around the
council
meetings um with the committee system
the council meetings are going the are
going to be that much Fuller because
they're going to be reports coming from
from the sub the
Committees what happens if we run out of
time at A4 council
meeting and we don't manage to go right
the way through the agenda will that
just automatically go straight on to the
next month's meeting or will you be
looking to slot in emergency meetings
for one of a better name uh to cover the
items that aren't covered within that
agenda if not you're going to get the
situation month on month things are
starting to build up like compound
interest so I'm just curious to know how
that particular part part
works councel nle thank you Council stto
um I think every council meeting has a
different amount of business on it so I
don't not see how you assume that there
will be a compound if you like of
business if it's a if it's urgent
business and time sensitive then of
course another meeting could be proposed
if it's not it will get rolled
over but I I do not understand some
meetings will have a few items on the
agenda some meetings will have a lot
we've had meetings even under this under
the old style of executive that we've
had Council meetings where indeed
motions haven't been heard for six to
eight months so I do not understand
where you're coming from on that because
you know experience tells us
that it it doesn't actually make it that
much quicker under under a cabinet
system so I think we need to keep an
open mind about this and as as I said in
my opening speech this will be reviewed
in 12 months and we can look at it if
there's a problem we'll change it it's
not set in stone and every member here
will have the opportunity to feed into
that and to give their their views on it
and make changes if they're needed thank
you thank M I think there been quite a
reasonable discussion on this and points
of view have been made I think we could
deal with this by having the vote
because you can put your feelings in a
vote so I intend if if it's agreeable to
do this on block three items are you all
agree right right so there are three
recommendations one that the proposed
committee structure and terms of
reference be agreed with effect from the
annual council meeting on the 21st of
May
2024 two that the calendar of the
meeting dates for 2024 to 25 be agreed
and three that the subject of the
agreement of of the recommendations one
the monitoring officer is instructed to
give public notice of revised governance
structure in accordance with the
requirements set out in paragraph 73 of
this report
are you all in
favor can you raise your hands those in
favor please are you voting are you
voting are you voting oh
sorry
thank you
members 23 for none against and 11
abstention so that's carried thank
you item 8 annual review of exempt
reports MERS this report is Just for
information and I believe it
self-explaining
however the council monitoring officer
Emily Yu is here to answer any questions
you might have members are there any
questions Cas
C uh thank you Mr chairman um yes I was
just uh curious as to why the review
date on a couple of items was uh down as
April 24 uh the ADP program and um April
27 for the um uh review of the ground
maintenance was it I think no the the
waste collection service um is that is
that a typo April 27 or is there a
contract that
uh yeah okay I thought that might be the
case thank
you Mrs thank you chman you you probably
saw me nodding um their members but it's
exactly that the review date is tied
into any length of contract that sits
over that um particular
paper thank you very much Emily that
doesn't apply to the ADP though
presumably can that review date be
brought
forward um thank you
chairman I've um so I suppose with the
um papers relating to the ADP I've put a
hopeful date for April 24 if the review
can happen earlier it will because part
of the revised process is about making
sure that as soon as a paper can be made
available we proactively do so uh but of
course if there is any reason that those
papers need to be need to continue to be
confidential beyond that that back stop
date I would observe
that c m m
thank you
chair I think members will realize that
this is the first time an exempt report
has been presented to members and the
public and I would like to congratulate
the leader for ensuring that this was
initiated and I trust that the openness
and transparency that this
Administration has demonstrated will be
continued going forward I would like to
ask
how the these are going to be published
because obviously time has lapsed since
these decisions were made and I think
it'd be helpful to know how we are going
to inform the public that the this
information is now available to them
thank
[Music]
you thank you chairman the um reports
that have now being released as public
documents already appear on our website
so they are in a single location um and
all of the reports um that have been uh
have had the exemption removed are
highlighted on the attached um table
with the report and members of the
public can link straight through to that
document from that report thank
you thank you members that be that's
okay then so right we now take item nine
agenda items nine council tax premiums
and I will now invite councelor Hoy to
uh to introduce this
report thank you chairman I'll do a
brief introduction to this report and
then I'll pass it on to um Mr Willis to
continue um and then he will pass back
to me and I'll do the recommendations
just so that's quite clear to everybody
this report is to introduce a council
tax empty homes un unoccupied and
substantially unfurnished dwellings
premium premium of 100% after one year
with effect from 1st of April 2024 and a
premium of 100% Second Home Premium
unoccupied and furnished dwellings with
effect from 1st of April 2025 for those
who want to know about the income this
will raise this is shown on page
9.8 and just to clarify the tabling 9.8
is the total amount we received
obviously some of that will be SS County
Council and some of that would be asked
but that's broken down in the paragraph
below I'll now pass on to Mr Willis to
continue
thank you
chair thank you Council H um as Council
said this report seeks approval for two
changes to the existing Council policy
regarding council
tax the these two changes have Arisen
due to government changes allowing local
authorities to increase the council tax
bills of owners of properties that are
vacant the first one is regarding the
empty property premium
um current Council policy is to charge
double council tax if a property is
empty and unfurnished for two years the
proposal is to implement the double
charge after only one
year existing policy for tripling
council tax after 5 years and
quadrupling it after 10 years remain the
same the second proposed change is
regarding second homes these typically
differ from long-term empties by being
furnished and used as second homes there
has in the past been no scope to apply a
council tax premium on these properties
The Proposal is to apply a double charge
on second homes there is no rule
requiring the property to be classed as
a second home for a year before imposing
the chain to the charge the premium can
be applied with no delay but there needs
to be a 12-month period between
introducing the policy and implementing
it so the first change to empty
properties can be effective from the 1st
of April 2024 but but the second change
on second homes can be effective from
the 1st of April 2025 thank
you members are there any questions so
far sorry chairman I was um then going
to move the recommendations
on the first
page which I'm at the bottom of the page
so I I'll be moving the recommendations
R1 to adopt the changes in 1.25 in
respect of dwellings which are
unoccupied and substantially unfurnished
empty home premiums with effect from 1st
of April 20124 and R2 to apply a premium
of 100% on second homes with effect from
1st of April
[Music]
2025 canel FD you wish to speak second
first we have a second
first yeah sorry I've got I've left me
here there before we go any further is
there a second to
your coun M councelor
FD thank you chairman it's just a
clarification on 1.4 I'll read it out
when determining the policy each billing
Authority has to decide the level of
discount if any gr to be granted which
billing Authority actually decides is it
us or
ess6 and because we got a property in
great waken which is run by charity
which is being build and they having to
pay the council tax not investing that
money in the building to bring it back
into use so it' be interesting to know
actually decides
this sorry could I pass that for Mr Wiis
to
answer um sorry chair could I have the
question again because I I didn't quite
catch it sorry
c um according to 1.4 when you
determining the policy bill in Authority
i' like to know which bill in Authority
is is it s us or Essex who determines
the
discount thank you it's us it's the it's
V District Council right so in in the
past the property I've discussed or just
said in great wakering they've got in
touch with us and they've always said no
you've got to pay the double or treble
premium and they having to pay the
double treble premium which is thousands
of pounds a year not being invest in the
building to bring the building back into
in line is there something with a
decision that's made doesn't seem to be
any logic to it that's sort of my
question what sort of
um concessions can we actually put in
for
them thank you chair um I think I I
understand um that if you're paying out
a lot of money in council tax premiums
you don't have the money to invest in
the property to bring it back into use I
think is the point that Council f is
making but I would suggest that the the
whole concept behind the policy is the
other way around it's to discourage
Property Owners to allow properties to
be empty in the first place and so they
don't then suffer the council tax
premiums as a
consequence come back quite on that but
the people have got the property or
charity or running it so usually we give
Charities
relief so thanks for the answering
I have one more go there's no charity Le
for council
tax anyone
else there are two um main
recommendations to to adopt the changes
in paragraph 125 in respect of dwellings
which are
unoccupied and substantially unfurnished
empty home premiums with effect from the
1st of April
2024 and second to apply a premium of
100% on second homes with effect from
the 1st of April 2025 members I propose
to take these recommendations on block
are you happy with that yeah right right
we have the proposition so all those in
favor of this
agenda
thank you members that's unanimous thank
you right item
10 reports from the executive and other
committees to
council report of the overview and
scrutiny committee treasury management
midyear review members are now invited M
counselor Mrs is Joe mcferson to
introduce his
report thank you
chairman members this is the second
treasury management report for the
financial year at the overview and
scrutiny committee on the 5th of
December the committee noted this report
and agreed its referral to for
Council the report highlights relatively
high but Falling inflation in interest
rates this is helping Investments the
late latest rates earned are around the
5% we forecast a surplus against budget
for investment income of 489,000 which
has been built into the current budget
monitoring position this Council has no
borrowing interest on borrowing would
currently cost in excess of
5% given the leading times for reports
I'd ask members to note that more
upto-date information is now available
regarding the economic update in
paragraph
3.1 specifically CPI in October was 4.6%
and core CPI in October was
5.7% I propose to the council that this
report be noted thank you chairman thank
you this this is just for noting
councelor Croft it's
just you
may thank you chairman um I do apologize
I wasn't at the uh committee meeting on
the 5th of December um and it may have
been discussed then but um I just made
an observation really in the rates of
interest paid on our deposits and whilst
I understand the need to spread risk it
appears that the greatest uh level of
interest is paid on a Sant andere um
instant access is considerably better
than the handles banken and uh the other
95 day one um so I I'm just wondering
why we haven't got a bigger percentage
of our money invested in the instant
access account that pays the best
interest
rate oh
you thank you chair um yes this is just
a matter of timing um as interest rates
go up and down at the point that we want
to invest uh uh several million pounds
in a particular account then we we will
take the interest rate that's available
then um and then the next day sometimes
it can be a different rate and over time
it obviously obviously moves so these
rates U the differences in the interest
rates in the table in paragraph
2.5.1 is the differentials are far more
reflective of the timing of the
investment than they are of the notice
period on the
accounts thank you for this thank you uh
Tim yes you'd expect um an account where
you have to give notice to be paying
usually a higher rate of interest that
isn't the case here so I'm wondering why
we haven't got more in the instant
access account that's currently paying
the highest rate of interest um it would
seem that to be a good idea to me to
switch um some of the other instant
money into that account can we do that
instant means instant after
all I think the off could take note with
that and take it back with him and we
can have a see what comes out of it I
think that thanks very much other than
that members I ask you to
indicate can Sim
what thank you very much indeed chairman
look I'm very grateful to councel Mrs
mcferson for drawing out number of
points I won't repeat them uh I think
she gave a very good report but uh if I
can just take you she did actually
referen 3.1 um and if I can take you to
the fifth um 1 two 3 for five fifth
bullet points um I think on point of
accuracy um if we're going to reference
percentages um according to my records I
think we ought to look at October
2022 uh
99.6% uh CPI um and that is when it was
at a 31e high um I think the figures
quoted for uh April and May are
technically wrong it should be 7.8% in
April 7.9% in May and on a downward
trajectory from a 31-year high uh but
certainly uh I think that to quote
August is a bit sloppy um bearing in
mind that we're now in December uh the
figures for November are out tomorrow
but certainly we've got the October
figures which show 4.7% on a downward
trajectory uh which may in the longer
term affect interest rates thank you
chairman thank you counc right I now ask
members if you would um if you could
indicate your agreement to note this
report we now move on to 10 102 report
of the chief offic appointments
committee appointment of the tier 2
chief officer and I now calling upon Mr
[Music]
Stevenson thank you chairman um thank
you members um in front of you report
10.2 with regard to um the appointment
of the tier 2 chief officer there was a
recommendation or appointment made at
the K committee on the 5th of December
um following an interview process um as
per our pay policy of June 2022 that
needs to come to this to council um to
be agreed um because the the
renumeration value is over 100,000 and
there is two recommendations as a report
and happy to take any questions if
required members it's important to note
that uh before we proceed to debate this
item I would like to remind you that
appendix a of this report is exempt and
we would therefore need to move to a
Clos session to proceed with this item
if you do wish to discuss any item on
this on this appendix I I'll give you
fair notes on that so please consider
that um are there any members who wish
to speak on the exempt
appendix
good right if members could indicate if
anybody that wishes to speak on on the
now just take
any anything at all nothing in that case
then I move the motion without not is
that the Press of public be sorry I'm
jumping the gun here can those members
in favor please have we
got sorry I propose that that
proposition made by the pay member pay
services be accepted do I have a second
that okay thank you m then I put that
toward you then I those all in favor of
moving that motion please indicate in
the usual
way
there any against any
against any
extensions members that motion has been
carried it's 30 two for and two
abstentions none against thank
you well move
on where we are
now agenda item 11 report on urgent
decisions there are no urg decision to
report item 12 agenda item 12 report of
the leader of of the work of the
executive I now invite councelor John
Mason to present the leader's
[Music]
report thank you
chairman uh as you might expect and
everyone should expect the executive is
currently centered on discussing and
bringing forward a budget to the budget
and council tax setting meeting on the
20th of February the CLT and the
executive are meeting in early January
for further discussions on hope final
discussions uh political groups have
been invited to meet with the interim
director of resources in January for a
budget
proofing member services have uh given
me a an early draft of the executive
committee meeting for the 25th of
January and I'm expecting to to have
reports from officers on the following
the UK shared Prosperity fund the grant
funding categories being brought forward
for
decision a one team health and safety
and well-being policy report putting a
new policy in
place the voluntary sector grants which
of course will be affected by changes at
Asic County Council and finally um but
importantly um the procurement strategy
a report from the Leisure contract
working
group thank you chairman
than you coun um well we now go to item
13 agenda item 13 public
questions Council
Ward thank you chairman um it's just a
question actually I I do remember over
the years that when a leader made any
report about the executive we normally
had a written copy in front of us out of
a courtesy um I I was expecting probably
to see one but I haven't has this
changed now is this not part of what the
leader does in allowing us to see a
written copy of what he has actually
been discussing thank you
chairman thank you Mr Cas motion yes
chairman I have changed it thank you
very much Council Ward I give a report
and it's reported in the minutes thank
you so
much thank you members thank you councel
m Mason right item 13 public questions
members on notice we've already had a
question one from Mrs Jill mate I now
refer to public question number two
members I will now invite Mr Andy Taylor
to read out his question to the lead
member of strategic
plan so again good evening thank you
chair for the opportunity to ask as my
question as you say my question is to
the lead member for strategic strategic
planning what progress has or is being
made towards the council's plan for the
provision for the Gypsy and travel sites
the lack of a plan is leaving next
existing residents vulnerable and
harming green belt and has led to
criticism by planning inspectors at
appeal when will a new plant be
available thank
you thank you Mr T thank you
right I'll call upon counselor Jim Crips
for a reply
[Music]
please thank you Mr Taylor and please
excuse my back I have to face the
microphone when I'm
talking as I actually see two questions
in your question and I'd like to take
the
second second one first
because that's fairly
straightforward it asks when the new
plan will be in
place pending the inspector approval in
the second quarter of
2025 that is when the new local plan
will become
live it will run from 2025 to 2040 and
cover that period it supersedes the
existing local plan
which was first allocated in
2014 you might like to know that next
year
2024 the public will get two
opportunities to review the pack that is
this local plan covering all maners
manner of things it will be
initially looked at as preferred options
which is the one we're working on now
but eventually after public consultation
that will come back in a final fall late
in
24 ready for the inspectorate in second
quarter
25 that is the sequence of events that
dictates when the new plan will be in
place I'd now like to move on to your
what was your first point in the second
one's a little bit more
complicated first of all I'd like to
start off with some some
history the ex in local plan included
gypsi and traveler accommodation
Provisions which has never been brought
forward the fact that 10 years has
elapsed underlines that there is not a
simple Silver Bullet
solution we
RC appointed an independent consultant
earlier in the year to to
produce a Egyptian travel
accommodation assessment that was
received
recently the office is in fact met with
the consultant again this Tuesday just
gone so we now have a baseline for the
present situation all the way through to
the end of
2014 there are for casts in there for
the future and thorough assessment of
the current situation which
was undertaken by surveys on every
single site in the district and
interviews with the owners or at least
the owners who wanted to be
interviewed that Baseline now is with
the
officers they will now work through that
and eventually a report statistics and
proposals and recommendation will come
forward to the planning policy
commission committee
sorry when it's approved it'll move
forward to the full Council for their
approval I'd just like to make the point
that the planning policy committee is
made up of three senior Administration
counselors and three senior opposition
counselors
plus myself as
chairman so this when it comes through
to us will get rigorously looked at by
very much a cross-party group of
people it's clear to me that as I said
before there is no single Silver Bullet
solution to this I think we'll want to
look at Short medium and long-term
Solutions so I trust that
will answer your question what progress
has and is being made thank
you thank you councelor
CS this concludes the the public
questions or
notice we will now move to members
questions or notice and the first
question or will now invite councelor
Dave sparing to read out his
question thank you chairman under the
conservative Administration plans were
put forward earlier in the year under
the place space Improvement program for
youngsters to install three brand new
skate parks at various locations across
the district ra Leisure Center hridge
and Clem Hall Recreation ground and
there was funding provision for all
three and the tenders were in advanced
stage at the executive meeting on the
16th of
November it was pleasing to note that
two of these have now been
approved however it is disappointing
that the one at Clem Hall is not
proceeding due to and the quote was
noise levels and the proximity to
Residence properties can the executive
leag member for leisure tourism and
wellbeing please elaborate as to why
thank you
chairman I call upon can jul good in to
reply thank you chair
um thank you councilor sparin for um
raising this
question uh before finalizing the award
of the contract to the appropriate Ward
The Ward members were invited to visit
all three
sites concerns were raised at Clem Hall
that the new location was only
approximately 65 m to the nearest
property as opposed to the 160 MERS of
the existing skate
park therefore it's felt prudent that
the proposed location for Clem Hall
skate park is reviews reviewed and and a
prop a consideration is given to the
potential impact upon local residents
before proceeding any
further I still expect that clens Hall
will receive a new skate park as you've
noted there's funding for it but it is
better to pause and review the location
than to proceed with what could have
been an expensive
mistake I hope that answers your
[Music]
question thank you councelor Gooding
councelor sparing to have a supplement
thank you chairman uh Council quing
perhaps you'd like to comment on these
views as well on the 24th of January
this year we had a site visit at Clement
Hall and I say we I include myself
councelor Mrs Mason Mr Aldridge and Mr
mclam from
RDC considerable time was spent deciding
on the site and its
appropriateness soft Landscaping was
considered to be planted to ensure
minimum noise nuisance to any residents
it was also anticipated that any noise
nuisance in addition to what was already
going on at clal would be absolutely
minimal I've subst heard in a subsequent
meeting that there was concerns about
light pollution I have no idea where
that came from because there was never
any intention of floodlighting for this
skate
area since the 24th of January until the
change of administration in May I
supported officers as they produced
their
tenders at no time in that period was
any criticism concerns or issues raised
about the site location caning can I
point you you should be sticking to the
question you are well I'm trying to get
to this chairman yeah but you seem to be
going around a long way to it can you
get to the point
okay no comment was made about the re
location this site now this suddenly
seems to have appeared I think it's very
unfortunate that the the young people
who live adjacent or near to Clem Hall
will not receive the skate park as was
originally intended at the same time as
the other two areas perhaps councilor
Mrs pudding would like to emphasize more
a pause what is a pause a week a year a
month just a bit of elaboration on why
this is not going his head sir thank you
thank
you m
good thank you councelor sparin uh I
agree with you this the this soft
Landscaping does seem to be a a very
good area however what wasn't taken into
consideration was the noise pollution
there was nothing about light pollution
as far as I'm aware um so and I can't
give you a definitive time I have asked
officers and they are working on that
and uh as soon as they can come back
with an answer for the time scale I will
advise you thank you thank you Mrs
Gooding right we now move on the
question two and then I call on
counselor Mrs laoren
Shaw thank you Mr chairman this is to
the executive lead member for finance
can the lead member for finance please
inform the council progress on the
independent audit process for signing
off the annual accounts for this and
previous years thank you thank you
councelor
Hoy thank you chairman and thank you for
the
question this Council has had its
accounts audited for the years up to and
including 2020 21 the 21 22 accounts are
currently in the process of being
audited the council ex the council's
external Auditors ernston young had
planned to complete the audit by now but
there have been delays some due to Eren
Young's ability to Marshal its resources
to begin and progress the audit and some
due to the council's finance team been
unable to respond to audit questions
because the original timetable when
Finance staff would have been available
had slipped the audit is now scheduled
for completion and reporting to audit
committee by March
2024 the council published draft 2022 23
accounts in June this year Ern and young
cannot give an indication as to when
they will begin the audit of that Year's
accounts there has been much discussion
at the national level regarding the
external audit of public sector accounts
with some indications that all 2022 23
audits will have to be complete by March
2024 this is yet to be confirmed but if
so it is likely to seriously undermine
the quality of any audit the same
predicament is faced by most other
public bodies as well as this Council
through no fault of their own some local
authorities have outstanding audits
dating back years before
2021-22 so Rochford isn't as badly off
as some but I'm sure councelor Mrs Shaw
agrees that the failure of in the system
of external audit undermines public
accountability and
transparency it is a personal
frustration that despite publishing our
draft accounts we await validation of
those accounts by the auditor my hope is
the relevant government agency set up to
fix this National problem will
facilitate the completion of the audits
to Prior year accounts and we can return
to a more normal footing from the audit
of the 2324 accounts thank you thank you
counc counc Mr Shaw have your
supplementary yes I have chairman excuse
me using your phone because it's on the
notes on the phone sorry given recent
news about the state of some local
authorities which have declared
themselves effectively bankrupt what
action is he taking to personally
provide public reassurance to residents
on the C council's current and future
financial position in a favorable
position and a and audit compliant but I
do apologize reading for my
phone coun you
have um I thank councelor Shaw for the
supplementary question
I the in my opinion the only thing which
can give public Assurance is an audit
which has been completed I refer Council
assure to the audit committee though
where questions can be asked and can be
put by any member about the accounts and
if they have concerns I believe that is
where they should put forward those
questions thank
you can I just come back that it would
be fine if the audit committee wasn't
Council on the point of order there is
only one supplementary question
allow right so we now move on to members
question three thank you members um the
final question or notice is councelor s
won thank you chairman and my question
is to the leader of the councelor
councelor John Mason um in the light of
a recent letter from Jacob young MP
Minister for leveling up can the leader
please inform members what his
administration's position is with regard
to Devolution in essics and more
importantly the considered benefits or
otherwise of such a decision to
residence within the Rochford District
thank
you coun
motion thank you
chairman and thank you councilor won for
your question The Joint Administration
welcomes the announcement by the leader
of ESS last week that there will be an
open public consultation on the cons on
the proposals for greater
eics The Joint Administration intends to
bring the public consultation to a full
C Council so that all members can
participate in the response from the
council to the
consultation Jacob Young's letter
answered some of the questions that the
that have been put by the districts but
there are other questions which need
further information given before the
council as a whole can make a considered
view the proposals for Devolution cover
economic functions around skills
transport business support and
investment but have now been extended to
the new local visitor economy
partnership elv I think that's what it's
going to be
called further a health Improvement duty
all with2 million of new capital
investment that amount does look thin as
a benefit to Residents and the intended
combined Authority needs the community
Comm unicate its priorities for that
spending further how will the costs of
the com combined Authority be funded
will District Representatives have a
vote the council will need further
information from the intended combined
authority to respond in a public
consultation thank you chairman thank
you councel m councel would would you
want to respond supplementary
thank you very much indeed uh chairman
and thank you indeed to um the leader
for his response and update which is
actually very helpful because it brings
us really up to speed but it does seem
that despite the lack of appetite by
residents I have spoken to for another
tier of governance which is essentially
what we're talking about Essex County
Council are continuing to push ahead
with their proposals for a level two
Devolution deal along with the two upper
tier authorities unitary authorities
South End on sea and thork as lower tier
authorities Castle point bzden and
Brentwood as well as rodford would be
excluded from the negotiations or be
it's pleasing to hear from the leaders
response tonight that might not be
totally the case but residents of course
in those four District stroke Burrows
are equally affected by the impact a
Devolution deal could have and in his
letter the minister certainly doesn't
appear to roll out a countywide combined
Authority although it's interesting uh
that Essex was not named as becoming one
of the Chancellor's recent autumn in in
the Chancellor's recent a Autumn
statement so will the leader commit to
ensure that as a district we are all
kept on the front foot with any
proposals coming forward and that he
will set out and write a letter
accordingly to the leader of Essex
County Council giving Clarity to his
administration's position whatever that
might be thank you
chairman thank counc wood counc
Mason chairman the um leader of Essex
has made it quite clear and indeed only
seven days ago that there will be an
open public consultation because of that
the just joint Administration Will Wait
we'll wait to hear the terms that are
being applied for by the three combined
authorities answer the questions that
I've already put you to you in answer to
your question and then this Council the
whole of this Council will be able to to
respond with a position thank you
chairman than chairman if I just raise a
point these are no these are questions
on no it's a point for chairman I need
some advice from the monitoring officer
as a member of the administration of
Essex County Council whether I need to
declare interest sorry I apologize for
that I told you do not need to sorry Mr
canc step toe I'll jump in up a bit
quick there right that ends the uh
members members on notice questions on
notice so we now go to notice of item 14
motions on notice there are three M
motions on notice and motion one I will
now invite Mrs E gladson to read out our
notice
on thank you chair um before I read up
my notice I'd like to acknowledge and
thank Mr Crips for his reply to Mr
Taylor's question I understand there's
no magic bullet we don't expect a Magic
Bullet but taking into the concerns of
our residents like Mr Taylor at the um
plan applications that we're facing at
the moment we do
need we do to take urgent action so I'd
like to start by saying inappropriate
applications have been made in the past
for gypsian traveler pitches on Green
Belt sites most recently one for two
pitches in tenders Avenue Ry and one for
two pitches in Magnolia Lincoln Road
haulwell in both cases point of order
Mr this isn't the motion that I have in
front of me I was reading an
introduction to my
motion you have to read your notice of
motion motion first sorry this is my
first motion to bear with me sorry coun
there's no preface to all of this right
so my motion on notice is that Rochford
District Council seeks planning
permission for all known occupied by
unapproved pitches with the intention of
these P these being recognized as
contributions to achievement of the
traveler and Gypsy commitment so can I
go on to my introduction now thank
you
second I'll second that
chair sorry chairman I'll second that
motion right so if it's okay pleas pleas
continue with my
introduction a key issue in the
recommendation for the approval was the
fact that the current local plan
allocation an area for Gypsy and
traveler site Mitchell Farm which has
not been delivered and that RC our
district Council has failed to deliver
an allocation for 15 pitches by
2018 in both cases described the
development committee made up by
counselors despite the
recommendations refused permission it
remains to be seen whether appeals will
be made though it would seem likely
because the applicant or someone acting
in favor of the Magnolia Lincoln
proposal allegedly paid in excess of
100,000k for green belt Land Based on
the mitchellan farm reasoning behind the
recommended approvals described above
Rochford District Council clearly
remains vulnerable to the most
inappropriate applications for travel
and Gypsy pitches on Metropolitan green
land however a number of pepper potted
pitches have been approved in the
current local plan period and also there
a significant number of occupied for
unapproved pitches in the Rochford
District in total these approved and
unapproved occupy pitches would satisfy
the obligation the reason for the OCC
occupied but unapproved pitches can be
included that the fact the opkins had
failed to apply for plan commission and
no enforcement action was being taken
this in seconding this motion Council
Foster will providing supporting
statistical
information planning provision for any
site can can be applied for by a person
or body that is not the owner of the
land and given the points I've made I
move that the motion on
notion noted
noted motion on notice or notice
sorry
gu you wish to
speak okay a step to oh sorry Cas the
fer you put you first thank you chairman
I'd like to speak in support of of that
motion in seconding it got to say
irrespective of what council said
earlier um this is background for the
moment does anybody actually know what
the need and legal obligation is for the
provision of gypsy and travel pitches in
rord District as councilor Gadson stated
inappropriate applications have been
recommended for approval by officers
Officer reports on the basis of
allocated land and pictures on bin Farm
not being delivered in the period up to
2018 the Gypsy and traveler
accommodation assessment report prepared
by opinion these are the reports
research service on on behalf of RDC in
June
2017 and on behalf of South Essex
councils including RDC in 20 April
2019 these reports were prepared in line
with the criteria designated in leg in
legislation and by RDC and can be
accessed on the actually on the council
website the June 2017 report identified
a need to be addressed for the period
from 2016 to
2033 a total of 19
pictures the April 2019 report
identified the need for the period from
2016 to
2038 for a total of 18 pitches the total
of 18 was made up of five on
unauthorized developments two on what we
described as concealed households and
doubling up and I emphasize a future
need identified for a total of just 11
yes 11 in that period from 2016 to
2038 these are the
reports so how many pictures do we
have uh Council gon been advised of
there being a total of 12 authorized
sites with 24 pictures in the district
and a requirement for a further T we've
not been advised how many of the 24 four
currently authorized pitches were
approved since the report in
2019 which would therefore contribute to
the Future need of the 11 identified
pitches from that period 2016 to 2038
however having done research on RDC
website which I've spent some time doing
since
2017 six planning applications with a
total of 12 pitches have been either
approved by development or on appeal
doing a search on the website doesn't
actually identify these applications so
I had to go back through uh development
committee records going back to 2017 to
pick up all these applications and their
approval they actually uh approved uh a
total of 12
pitches okay I've got all those
application numbers I can share with you
later if you wish arguably those 12
approved could satisfy the requirement
identified in the RDC commissioned
reports through the period 2016 to
2038 however moving to the point of the
motion on notice I do feel we hostages
to fortune on the issue of and we need
absolute Clarity on our legal
obligations and delivery delivery of
sites we've seen reports saying one
thing officer saying something
different officers are advised there are
currently 17 pitches which are occupied
but do not have planning approval as
such they're not included in any
evaluation of provision of pitches it's
clear that these fall under the radar in
recognizing the current provision of
pitches in the rord district council
area and assessments are made of what we
would describe as inappropriate
applications of pitches in Green Belt
areas similarly in appeals inspectors
take no account of these pitches we
believe that the time is long overdue
when all existing pitches are taken into
consideration versus the requirement
when further gypsian traveler pitch
applications have been
assessed in order to achieve this we
believe it's necessary one minute left
the occupied and unapproved pitches
become approved if the occupants of
these unapproved pitches declin to seek
planning approval the purpose of the
motion on notice is to require RDC to
make planning applications for all of
these pitch locations which would bring
them under consideration when
applications have been
made this would we believe in the short
and medium-term protect RDC residents
from inappropriate applications but I
would emphasize that I do not believe
and we are not proposing that melin's
farm is removed as an allocated site for
the gyps and traveler pitches we firmly
believe that it should be developed in
order to provide longer term protection
against inappropriate Green Belt
applications for Egyptian travel of
pitches I would also add that I believe
there should be a clear report to
clarify our obligations including a
directory of all current sites both
approved and unapproved your CH now up I
second the motion and request a recorded
vote thank
[Music]
you so you want to recorded vote
y okay
G you wish to speak yes thank you chair
uh when this motion first uh came
through the email I uh took the
opportunity to speak to our planning
manager uh about the uh the whole uh
proposal um I do sympathize with the
purpose of this report uh this motion um
the problem that we do have though is
that uh we could be preempting something
here now whereas you've given us lots of
figures is based on your uh
historical
uh
investigations um the problem is that we
uh as Council crys has already said that
we are awaiting I believe we do actually
have a a provisional idea on what is
going to be the actual uh
requirement and the expectation at the
moment is that is going to be
considerably higher than what it
actually uh is
currently there is another issue as well
in that one of the big sites uh along
the end of rorth
Lane um that one is more than likely
going to be a bit of a problem uh in
putting forward for planning permission
purely and simply because it uh is too
squeezed in and would not actually get
planning
permission now the the the question that
I have here although I just say I have
every sympathy with the the motive
behind
this are we actually in a stage where we
are preempting something and we are
beginning to get into a situation of not
taking any notice of what the uh the
current situation is going to be and
thereby the expense that is going to be
for Rochford Council to actually apply
for the planning permission on these is
going to be
high and if we are still waiting for
what the allocation is going to be the
expectation is that we could go through
this whole exercise and still not meet
our allocation and so from that point of
view I am going to abstain because I
think that this is preemptive and we
need to actually wait for the
information that is coming forward that
has been asked for and is being
processed thank
you counc crys you be
next
thank you
chair I'm a little bit surprised that
something of this magnitudes coming
through this
route if a suggestion like this was
coming through from any of our
committees it will be supported by
report statistics evidence-based
proposals
recommendations I think we are already
doing what's been asked via the due
process of the planning policy
commission
committee as I said in my earlier answer
to a public question I just like to
highlight a few
points the existing land the existing
local plan has been in place for 10
years in that 10
years the original allocation has never
have been for
forward I maintain my view that there is
no Silver Bullet
solution we've appointed an independent
consultant to do an indepth long-term
medium-term shortterm analysis which
we've recently received which the
officers are going through now and which
will go to the planning policy committee
I believe that due process is what this
should go through if we're going to get
a policy for the future that's more
effective than the one we had in the
past so I'd like to move a motion which
I think will
satisfy am Amendment the motion which I
think might satisfy the situation and
steer it back to where it needs to be in
due
process I'll read it out for you
now that Rochford District council's
planning policy committee explores the
option of seeking planning Miss for all
known occupied but unapproved pitches
with the intention of these being
recognized as a contribution to
achievement of the Gypsy and traveler
commitment this option may be recognized
in the context of the identified need in
the said independent Gypsy and traveler
accommodation
assessment do you have a
second I'd like to second that uh
proposed amendment from councilor
grips so we take the
V to see the propos in the second of the
original
to
acceptation do you accept that no can I
just
say and I don't get don't if I'm doing
this in the wrong order please stop me
but the issue is now I understand you've
got a process and you've got to go
through it but we are facing spurious
applications on Green Belt land now we
have residents want this point of order
we've got a full counil that can resolve
this now why push it to a committee when
you right we are we are debating the
amendment I'm not going to get involved
in personalities or personal views we
stick with the the what's in question
otherwise I should just close this down
and we'll take it on another time so if
you want to behave we'll behave but
don't get out of order any of you right
so we're now discussing the amendment
are there any questions on the amendment
councel
Steptoe thank you chairman I was going
to speak originally on the original
motion but now speaking to the
amendment um I'm very concerned about
delaying things and stretching things
out one of the things that I'm very
concerned about is particularly and it's
been mentioned by councilor
EES The gypsian Traveler site at
rorth been there for quite some consider
considerable time um I think most people
on the council world will be a few few
of us that will remember it but that was
actually um has an enforcement order
account it but that
was um dealt with by John Prescott when
he was Deputy Prime Minister so that's
how far back it
goes so really I think it is time now to
actually look at how we can regularize
that in Myst
bag I get lots of emails particularly as
my ward is very
rural and I get a lot of questions and
worries about pieces of land that
suddenly come up for sale
around the possibility of traveler
sight we need to protect and we need to
reassure those
residents that we can somehow stop the
inspectors just continuing
to issue planning permissions on
this unless we put something in place
fairly rapidly and I work on the
planning
policy I don't feel that it's going to I
think it'll be wrong to leave it and
stretch that out we could be talking 25
26 before that actually comes into place
we could have dozens of applications in
the meantime going forward something
needs to G done to stop that from
happening and that's why I will go back
to the original motion and support the
original
motion hey counc stto who we got counc
Bel thank you um I completely recognize
Council crit's comments about going
through the committee and I don't think
the amendment is unreasonable however
timing was and still is of the essence
we have had applications come forward
that have been approved um we have had
developments we've had applications go
to appe pill and one so the reason for
doing this now is because we are facing
the problem right now um councilor Eve's
comment about needing more sites
potentially off the back of the report
if anything that strengthens the reason
to move this motion forward now because
we can authorize some sites over the
next six 12 months which then leaves
less to deal with in the new local plan
so whilst I don't think Council cp's um
amendment is unreasonable I don't want
to support it because I think we can
make a really positive and safe decision
for this District tonight and then do
the other work in the background to deal
with the other sites and the other
numbers that we may have to consider in
the future so this is something that I
think a lot of us in this room are
passionate about our residents are
certainly passionate about it and I
think we've got an opportunity to do
something decent together to protect
some of our green belt in the short term
thank you thank you councelor Bill I'll
take councelor James newort I've got
your name
Daniel thank you chairman um it's not
often that I'll take a swipe at um the
conservative group but I think this
motion is pretty damn Rich coming from
them to be honest um both councelor
sparing and councelor Foster have
chaired the planning policy committee we
now suddenly there's some sense of
urgency to resolve this issue what were
they doing
can we stick with the amendment because
we're discussing having any debate on
the amendment if I may please continue
on but just stick with the amendment
this amendment that councelor Crips has
brought forward to
council uses evidence not Pine the sky
figures apparently the planning
inspector will take a view that the
original motion would stand and that
would be okay with there's no evidence
behind that that a plan inspector would
support that position and I think we're
just putting our residents at further
risk thank you
chairman councel Hoy did you wish to
speak I did but um councelor new said
pretty much what I was going to say
thank you councelor Mrs
Mason thank you
chair I've listened with absolute
surprise to this debate
because earlier in this
meeting counselor the leader was asked
if he he was providing a paper of
something very very simple that he' read
out and yet now we're asked to make a
serious decision with something where
we've got no written
documentation no objective
report all we have is opinion so I
support the amendment by councilor Crips
it's proactive it's
positive and we are much better as a
council taking time and we're not
talking months and years we're not
talking the decades that have been
passed where decisions weren't made by
the previous administration we're
talking about a relatively short time
span where we can make the time to make
a a decision that is not rushed and that
is not flawed and that will best serve
our community with the information that
is so sadly lacking tonight thank
you thank you cancel Mr
Shaw no sorry I was
trying chairman I was trying to indicate
that uh Council FD looked like a wind
farm trying to indicate that he wanted
to speak to you thank you
thank thank you chairman um the things I
discussed were not opinion they were
based on factual reports that rord
District Council Commission
with numbers projected through to
2038 and the argument is we've delivered
largely anyway the reason for the
urgency is as you know in your ward
there's been a gypsian traveler
application recently on Green Belt which
was refused by the development committee
based on some of the financials we
understand involved I'm quite sure will
come to appeal in in the not too distant
future so I do believe that it's
important that we get on with this now
rather than waiting for the development
of the new local plan thank you thank
you councelor Foster councelor Mrs
mcus thank you chairman you'll be
pleased to know I'm going to keep this
brief um I can understand the
urgency however I do feel that we would
need reports to make a decision such as
the the motion that's been put forward
originally the amendment I would like to
ask councilor Crips listening to both
sides of the argu doent if there's any
possibility of some sort of time limit
on when this will be done and I think
that that might perhaps rest more
comfortably with everybody in the room
thank
you thank you I'm I'm leaving you last
councelor Crips because I want you to
sum it up if I may please so next I've
got cast
refy sorry chairman um could he could
councelor Crips not come back on my
question it might
help thank you chairman
well if you're happy to but I want to
get on with this so you know if you wish
do Mr
problem can I put a number on it a time
scale I'm the chairman of the committee
um I don't direct
them to that extent of detail so we'd
have to put a Time on it I agree but I'm
not going to answer that here throwing
that without talking to my uh committee
members on what we can
achieve but I will take this opportunity
to highlight again something I said in
the public
address we need not one thing we need
three things a
shortterm policy a medium-term policy
and a long-term policy I'm well
aware of what's going on my ward has got
the biggest percentage of such sites in
the district so I'm very tuned into it
so when I say short medium and long I
will be looking to doing something in
the short
term I'm not going to put a number on
that short term until I spent for the
committee members thank you democracy
thank you C
refd thank you chairman um talking to
time scale we had a development meeting
not the last one but the one before
where these two sites come up and their
planning consultant sat there and
threatened us saying that I'm going to
take you to appe pill and I'm going to
flee you for whatever we can get out of
you if you don't agree this sites now so
it needs to be done about this we cannot
be held
hostage we we we are we think twice
about turning s down because of an
appeals decision when a planning
consultant sits down and threatens us
it's just totally wrong we need to do
something in the time
scale yeah have
to
so I'll just take counc wood now then
please thank you chairman
um unfortunately Council meetings always
tend to get this political knockabout
and I'm going to try and ride above that
um unfortunately what happens in Council
meetings is a published a published um
motion goes out and then on the night an
amendment is put forward and the trouble
is that I think the amendment makes an
awful lot of sense and actually I don't
think there's too much difference
between us in terms of I I agree with
what councelor Crips he wants to put
some structure uh he wants to put some
definition he wants it to be informed
and certainly he will resist making any
agreement on a motion on the hoof so I
actually totally get that and I don't
have a problem the difficulty is through
our process that have the two of them
spoken before the meeting because that
is how you would resolve these things
rather than bring a Amendment or a
motion and get that political knockout I
don't think there's much between them
and actually somehow chairman I think
that five minutes needs to be taken out
to actually get them to talk to each
other so they can come up with a motion
because the spirit of what we're all
talking about is exactly the same there
is no difference between us thank you
chairman thank can re you're going to be
the last one I think enough's been said
and we're going to have to have a vote
and finalize this so are you did you put
sorry I'm sorry there' be counc mo to
counc re and then we're going to call it
a vote okay thank you chair can I just
uh pick up on something because this has
become very emotive and as chairman of
the development committee of the said
applications that came forward I did not
hear a threat to the council so to
actually say no I did not hear a threat
to the
council no no I'm not having that and if
you actually look at the uh agreed
minutes that we had there's no threat to
the the Council made there the thing is
that what we are talking about here
councelor Crips has given an assurance
that we will have a short-term
medium-term
long-term that we don't have a report
here as he has given an assurance as the
lead member of the uh the committee that
is looking at this surely we should be
actually acknowledging the fact that he
has given this Council and Assurance for
exactly that thank you thank I'm take Mr
C Mason and then we're going to go to a
vote thank thank you chairman um this is
not the very first time that this issue
has been raised in full Council I did so
some years ago it was urgent
then and it's still urgent now one of
the very first things that councelor
Crips and I discussed when I became
leader and he
became lead member for the local plan
and strategic planning was I I wrote to
him and I wrote to the director of place
and I raised it because I was so
disappointed that there was no coherent
effective policy in place and I wanted
that brought forward I can't remember
the exact months but it was probably
only 3 months ago
one of the things I asked for was a
consultant report we now have that
Consultants report it is appropriate and
I agree with councilor mcferson that
this issue of how we deal with it goes
properly through planning policy both in
the short medium and long term as part
of the local plan so I'm in full support
of the amendment because is is the right
and proper way of taking forward policym
matters thank
you thank
you did anybody write down what the
amendment was so we could repeat the the
wording
or C Nole If You Could Read you've got
it down
there okay members right the the
amendment is rord District council's
planning policy committee explores the
option of seeking planning permission
for all known occupied but unapproved
pitches with the intention of these
being recognized as a contribution to
achievement of the Gypsy and traveler
commitment this option may be recognized
in the context of the identified need of
the independent Gypsy and travel
accommodation
assessment right so I'm say all those in
favor of the amendment
thank you members those
against
[Music]
well members that amendment is is
approved and it's uh 21 for eight
against and three abstentions therefore
that motion is
carried we go to
next Mr chairman can we can I ask for a
5 minute uh Comfort break please I know
we haven't got many to do but I'd like a
comfort
[Music]
break sorry to interrupt you I'm not
sure was that meant to be a named to
vote the last one thank
you sorry point of order chairman I'm
not sure if we're suspended or not
theing orders but don't we have to
actually vote on the substantive motion
now as
amended yes I'm just about to announce
that councilor Hoy but thank you right
so we're now we'll now go back to the
amended motion which was where is
it as amended
this one
here we just did it really but point of
order chairman if I member has a call of
nature that they must urgently attend to
it's a bit disrespectful not to actually
respect that isn't it the C wouldn't
they did ask me and I said if you would
wait a moment while we just discussed
this and they got up and walked out I'm
not here to wait for people to wander on
and off as it pleases them you know I
understand people want to go I'm in the
same position but a little bit of
respect I mean if if they want to go
they can go and if they're not here when
I want to talk that's that's the way it
is so we'll carry on so the I'll Now
read this out to Gypsy and traveler
pitches Rochford District Council
planning policy committee explores the
option of seeking planning permission
for all nonoccupied but unapproved
pitches for the intention of these being
recognized as a contribution in
achievement to the Gypsy and travel
commitment this option may be recognized
in the context of the identified need of
the independent gyps and travel
accommodation
assessment that is the substantiate
motion there so do we take another
vote so does anybody else want to speak
to the motion okay does anybody want to
speak on that relation to that
motion excuse chairman I'm a little bit
confused because we've had a um an
amendment and a motion which sort of
overrides this stantive motion so if
this stantive motion is turned down
would the amendment still
stand thank you chairman um just to
clarify the process uh you've had an
amendment proposed and seconded the
council has then voted on that Amendment
and that amendment has been carried that
now becomes the substantive motion and
the substantive motion is still
available to be debated uh so
essentially you're now
uh debating the amended motion um all
members who haven't already spoken on
the substantive motion have the option
to speak and debate that new substantive
motion and um at the end of that the
recorded vote that you requested earlier
will then come into play so that's when
we'll do the named roll call style vote
thank
right first
uh thank you chairman um in the context
of the amended uh motion and the
discussion about short medium and long
term bearing in mind the urgency of
situations that we've we've seen
recently in relation to planning
applications could we get some
indication what the uh chairman of the
planning policy committee can commit to
as a short-term achievement of that
assessment bear bearing in mind bearing
in mind as I said before the reports of
rer District Council had and uh has
achieved the objectives in so
far C
Crips I'm sorry I must uh respond to
councilor Foster the former chairman of
the planning policy
committee it didn't sit for 11
months I have had a planning policy
meeting once a month since I took over
we've had six meetings the next meeting
is already set for the 16th of January
because of the Christmas break in this
short
month thank
you thank coun Crips counc Foster sorry
I I come back I'm not criticizing the
frequency of council cps's U meetings I
fully support that I'm asking for a
timing on the short term be in mind
we've got a Now problem with gypsian
traveler applications
on Green Field sites and uh we don't
seem able to defend them when
actually what is available and I keep
saying it Rochford District Council
commission reports would provide us with
the evidence to to uh refute them so I'm
simply asking what is the definition of
shortterm in achieving the M can I just
say that we've had a big discussion over
this amended just now on the amending of
the a proposal and we' discussed it now
we're back to that as because it's been
approved as an amended proposition um do
you feel that you need to discuss what
we've already discussed I mean that's my
point so well if I may chairman I'm not
challenging the motion I'm asking
whether the chairman of the planning
policy can put a time scale to what he
defines a shortterm point of order
chairman that question has already been
asked and it's been
answered okay
chairman there's something very pivotal
um relating to what we're discussing
tonight I don't have a planning officer
here I've got no one to advise the
Council on the the merits and demerits
of the the the planning um mechanism
that's been put without that I find it
difficult to support any motion but I
will support a motion that takes takes
this to the proper place and the proper
place is planning policy committee where
we have a director of place advising the
committee and the committee then reports
back to full Council I'm very sorry
nothing will change after May that is
the
process here a cribs do you want to
something
out yeah I want to re reiterate Council
cross's point
councelor mcferson asked me to put a
Time on it I said I wasn't prepared to
do that until I speak to the members of
the committee of which Mr counselor Ian
Foster is a member so I should be
Consulting him directly on that subject
I also clarified my short-term
medium-term long-term approach to this
that is a commitment from me I'm already
working on it and have been for some
some
time so the motion as per councelor
won I think is a very positive move
towards what was being asked in the
first place we're not a million miles
away and I think that serves the purpose
and gets it down the due process route
orbe it a speedy one in terms of short
term and I think that that is the only
way we should be conducting business
quite frankly thank you members I think
we've discussed this in some length
already and we're just going over and
over the same thing I'm GNA give Mr
councelor Ward a chance but I'm going to
go for a vote so councelor
Ward thank you chairman I think the
concept of cooperation is essential this
is across the whole Council and it
affects our residents as a whole I think
the motion bought by councelor Gaston
had worth in it because it was seeking
to solve a problem
urgently taken in consideration I think
what council of Crips has actually put
forward is very very good I would also
like to add that I know councelor Foster
has been waving this around we will be
bringing this to planning policy we will
show planning policy exactly what this
Council has put in place what is there
these are the facts this is the evidence
that shows absolutely we have enough
sites we don't need to worry about this
our officers unfortunately have not
taken this into consideration for
whatever reason I'm not going to I'm not
going to talk about that particularly we
will discuss this in planning policy the
only thing that's important to all of us
is that we are able to get through this
and come up with a solution as quickly
as possible and this is across the
council this affects us all this is not
political I want to take the politics
completely out of this This concerns us
all councelor Mason has the problem over
there in haulwell with uh that place
over there we
chairman of order
chairman
please councilor Ward is making a speech
and not speaking to the amendment I'll
take I'll take your point but thank
you we've had enough discussion and I'm
going to put a p to it now because you
can reflect on what your feelings are in
the vote I know you've asked for a
recorded vote and we're going to take a
recorded vote on that amended
proposition
so okay so all those in favor of sorry
we're going to take recording vote so
son is going to be calling your name so
please be
attention
counselor counselor Mrs Bon
for counselor Mrs Brewer
for counselor Mrs
butcher
for counselor Constable
against councelor
KPS
councelor cross
for councelor
FD
for councelor EES four councelor
Foster
four counselor Mrs
gadston four if this is the only way I
can get my motion working coun Mr
Gooding counselor Mr
Gooding counselor Mrs Gooding
for councelor Hoy for councelor Knight
for councelor lamorne for councelor
lurman
for councelor Lindon for councelor Mrs
Mason councelor Elliot
Mason councelor John
Mason counselor Mrs
mcferson C coun Mr Newport
for councelor Mrs Newport
for councelor Mrs page
for councelor Sharp
for councelor Mrs
Shaw counselor sparing
for counselor Mrs squar
Coleman councelor Stanley for
councelor stepto
for councelor
Ward for councelor Williams
for councelor Mrs Wilson for councelor
won
for
[Music]
thank you members right that motion has
been carried it's 33 for one against and
one no extensions thank
you we'll now take uh motion two uh and
I invite m m councelor Mrs eing gadston
to read out the motion on
notice that this Council helps protect
its residents by signing up to a loan
Charter that expresses the council
commitment to fighting loan shks shks
that the executive investigates how
existing credit unions are working with
other local authorities to support their
residents with the cost of living crisis
and if required the executive
incorporates any Financial costs into
the
budget recently as a member of the cost
Del living group I suggested that
supporting in uction of a credit union
into the Rocha District may be a way of
supporting many of our residents that
are just about managing generally known
as Jam those who are entitled to
benefits but who are not entitled to
benefits but are struggling due to the
rising cost of living unfortunately due
to time rates my report was not
available but I have made that to make
it available to the chairman of the
working
group we all know too many of our hard
press residents are being faced with
invidious choices to keeping the homes
running denied access to mainstream
finance a broken washing machine or a
new school uniform can be enough to push
hard squeeze families over the edge
having nowhere to turn but the likes of
play payday lenders High Street ripoff
rent to own merchants or Worse illegal
loan charts can mean families entering
irreversible debt spar that pours
further hardship and budgets that
already far too tight credit unions are
communitybased Financial cooperatives
owned by members that help members save
offer Fair alone costs and offer
Financial education for for adults and
children credit unions are not just
driven to make money for external
shareholders but must make decisions in
the best interest of their members as
well as as well as offering accessible
affordable loans and saving products
they can also help set up credit unions
and schools to help to support the
future Generations own valuable personal
financial SK management skills all I ask
is this this administration supports my
motion
chairman I'm happy to Second this but
reserve the right to speak later if I
may thank
you councelor Mrs
mcferson thank you chairman um I would
speak in support of this uh the report
came forward um in the working group
that looks into cost of living crisis
set an up a credit union isn't an
overnight fix it does take some
investigation but that is all the this
motion is looking for is for this
Council to investigate looking into
setting up a credit union perhaps
following in the footsteps of many other
councils so I do think it's worth
supporting thank
you coun Mr
Mason thank you
chairman um I I've been involved um with
the setting up of a credit
union um it was whilst I was working for
for a bank and the dasis of chumford
reached out and we set up the Wei
um the ESS Credit Union was set up and
it ran for a few years sadly uh one of
the things that happened was it couldn't
meet capital capital adequacy
requirements and that was something it
was very sad and it actually
collapsed and um
clearly one thing about credit unions is
that they have to be set up with the
proper monitoring and compliance with
the F
fscs and I am I'm advised that it now
takes at least one year to set up a
credit union and what council person
says is quite right is that it is very
technical it does require a great deal
of work we will probably have to find a
sponsor within which to make it work and
the great deal of work will have to be
considered in respect of the the level
of financial support the credit union
will get to enable it to fulfill all of
the fcss
requirements right having said that I
support the the motion now I'm not sure
sure where the motion is in this but let
me let me tell you what I think it
is this motion proposes this Council
helps protect its residents by signing
up to a charter that expresses the
council's commitments to fighting loone
shards furthermore as an integral part
of this there is a call for action for
the executive to investigate as a matter
of urgency how credit unions are working
with other local authorities with the
intention to create a similar scheme in
Rochford to support residents any
resulting financial implications of this
need to be in the
2425 budget that's what I am speaking
to now speaking to it I've already said
I'm I am supporting the motion I hope
other members do I've noted the
imperative of urgency and because of
that I spoke to the chief executive I
asked him if he would be able to agree
with me to allocate officer time for an
urgent report on all matters referred to
in the motion and I've just read it
out and that depends on whether full
Council pass it passes it tonight it's
in your
hands the CEOs
agreed so I would would like the
executive to have the widest perspective
of of inputs from members and hearing
that it came up through um the overview
and scrutiny committee working group
then my my request is this if it's
passed tonight then I would like to
see the report which is going to be
urgent put to the ons committee on the
1st of
February and if it go go to the ons
committee on the 1st of February the
executive committee meets on the 15th of
February and that's ahead of the of the
full Council budget meeting on the 20th
of February I hope you can all see and I
hope councelor won in particular with
his reference to the previous motion
will see that I am actually reaching out
to the person to the people including
himself who are putting the motion and
coming up with a mechanism for it to
happen
I'll rest there because I want to hear
the views of other members of the
council and I do hope that this motion
gets passed thank you chairman thank you
Cas M
[Music]
Mason thank you chair I think councilor
Mr Mason is getting very familiar here
um actually has said um roughly what I
was going to say about the motion
because I heard a speech and I was
wasn't quite sure where the motion was
but as he's clarified that I don't think
any of us have would have any objection
to a credit union being formed that
helps our
residents I do have concerns about the
time scale but if the CEO and the leader
have managed to time that out then
that's excellent and I will be
supporting the motion as it stands thank
you thank you ccer
standing thank you
chairman whilst I'm supporting the
motion for Credit Union I just wonder
where the council stands in its
authority to
challenge the loone Sharks and what
we're going to do with them in in
conjunction with taking them to court
and so on in that performance of the
council
whilst we have
quite a uh a few problems with our
budget I'm not too sure if there is any
financial gain out of this not financial
gain out of this for the council but for
the residents of the council as we are
in that financial difficulty at the
moment I do believe but nevertheless I
do believe there is a
good scheme to go for if we are if it's
possible to go for that but how we would
how we would uh policy it how we would
police it with the police is another
matter thank
you thank you councelor
Hoy thank you chairman um in principle
I'm not against this motion however got
concerns
I'm councelor Mason read out the points
I don't know what Charter I'm signing
I've not seen the wording on I've got no
idea what it says I can't sign a charter
I don't know it doesn't seem
reasonable I'm also concerned about
putting something into the budget at
this point which we don't know the
costings of I would prefer it if
Council John Mason to make this clear
proposed an
amendment to the motion which puts
forward his proposal of it going to on
committee and then to the executive via
that route so what is agreed is properly
looked at rather than I've got I've got
no problem about the rest of it but I'd
rather it was formally approved that way
is that something Mr John mtion can do
okay motion was that an amendment it was
request for Mr John Mason to make an
amendment no chairman it it wasn't a
proposed amendment I'd like the the
motion to stay as it is um I recognize
that the charter wasn't made explicit
but nevertheless I've asked for an
urgent report which I expect it to be
made quite explicit as to what we're
being asked to sign up to um all I was
doing was setting up a um a mechanism
explaining a mechanism within the
council's parameters within my within my
agreement currently not not as leader
from from May onwards um I will be an
ambassador wouldn't I um but
nevertheless we can we can take this
forward in that way so all I was setting
out was a way of seeing that imperative
urgency being Ina
enacted members um conscious of the time
I if you could keep it simple and brief
can I ask counselor Mrs mil
Wilson thank you chair I'd just like to
say I totally agree with the sentiments
um of this motion um I have had some
small experience of um Credit Unions um
in a previous life um I know that they
are quite complicated and very time
consuming if they're going to be run
properly um I would very much like to
see this Council work alongside um um
another organization who would actually
perhaps run the credit union themselves
I totally agree with um um eradicating
loan shars as far as we can but in my
own personal view I don't think the
council is the right place to run a
credit union thank you chair thank you
members it appears that we are somewhat
in agreement I'm going to let councelor
cross and councelor EES have their say
but I need to put through for an
extension of we're running out of time
so if you would please bear with me on
this because we are getting to the
limits um councelor Mrs sorry councelor
cross uh thank you Mr chairman I I was
just going to bring a little bit of
light-heartedness into this it's the
season of Goodwill um we've all seen the
film It's a Wonderful Life and I think
some of us have also seen the bank of
Dave the these cases are similar to what
we're proposing here it's just in a
different name so I'll be supporting
this motion I think if we can eliminate
you know lone sharks and user useres Etc
charging extortionate rates of interest
to people that can least it I think
that's a great thing to do thank
you okay members due to time I mean it
seems a very um agreeable session
but C wouldn't do to quickly say
something thank you chairman I was
reserving my right to uh speak at the
end of the uh debate on this um and
first of all I'm extremely grateful to
councelor John Mason for picking out the
substance of the motion which he's quite
rightly done uh albeit they needed to be
a bit of Preamble uh it's fascinating
what you actually pick up in debates uh
because councelor John Mason was
involved with the Essex Credit Union as
was I U but our paths never crossed but
uh we might have a little bit bit of a
debate about some of the issues uh that
caused that sadly to close we will
probably have very shared similar views
about certain aspects of that um and it
was against that background that when
counselor Mrs gadston first spoke to me
uh I must admit I um perhaps didn't
receive the suggestion with the
positivity that actually the subject
deserves because when you have an
experience uh you speak in the light of
that experience but that is not a reason
not to uh reflect on the fact that this
motion is excellent in terms of its
intention and I think to come up with an
suggested Amendment we know what the
spirit is we know what the intention is
and there's clearly got to be some
structured governance that sits around
it we know that there are many
individuals through no force of their
own are excluded from benefiting from
the primary banking or lending sector
many of them fall on particularly hard
times and a good decent people who may
have a short-term need for an item like
a broken household item repairing their
car which is essential transport to
enable them to continue to work whilst a
nonstatutory
service we should be doing everything we
can creatively and morally do to support
our residents and protect them from
unethical practices adopted by some
money lenders and whilst I applaud
councelor Stanley's uh wish to deal with
these people uh unfortunately in
Practical terms it's probably not within
our gift even though I understand his
his sentiments so setting up a credit
union or something of the sort is one
such way with the carat that it is
managed and regulated responsibly uh and
I'm sure that will Echo some thoughts
with uh with councelor John Mason so I
wholeheartedly support this motion thank
you chairman
than b can you have fin please yeah can
I just come back on Clarity um it was
never the intention that the council run
a credit union it would be working with
an existing Credit Union I have made
some inquiries I found one that's been
working with other councils and that
report I was hoping although it's gone
to the working group would be shared
with the administration so what I was
asking is that they investigate the work
I've done also the charter wasn't was
more about helping people avoiding go to
loan charts loan charts not trying to
deal with loan shark straight on as an
Administration as a council
um and with regarding um Credit Unions
Etc the
benefits they they also provide life
life insurance for members so there's so
many more benefits than just um loans
and savings so I'd like to thank you for
bearing with me today's been my first
day of putting motions and um the cart
before the horse on a couple of
occasions but I thank John for picking
up on the
as it should have been read and I've
learned today and hopefully in future I
will put things the right way around but
thank you very much supporting my motion
it's really passionate I'm really Keen
thank
you members therefore the time's
pressing um I'd like to put this to the
vote then please and all those in favor
of this motion please
indicate everybody
unanimous
it's not back
not2 thank you members those
against those
abstaining 1
and4 members that motion is carried
thank you and we've got four abstentions
sorry no no objections thank
you right I yeah I have to Now read to
you the extension of meeting we're now
looking at nearly 5 to 10 uh this is to
be read out of the meeting right so um
members the meeting is now lasted nearly
two hours I'd like to move a motion
without notice according to the
council's procedure rule 14 netn to
extend the meeting beyond the two and a
half hours for as long as necessary in
order to complete the remaining business
do I have a
second not say do I have a second for an
extension C step
time we're now going to have a no vote
to weather extend beyond the 10:00
period so all those in
favor right thank you all those
againsts 20110
20 thank you members right we will not
be extending we'll be concluding very
short shortly um the vote is
204 uh against rather and 10 for so that
means that the last no notice of motion
the motional notice that was on the
agenda will have to be carried through
to the next four council meeting um I do
apologize for those wishing to put it
but that's our rules and we won't have
time to talk discuss that motion so as a
result of that
um there's nothing else is it yeah right
as a result of then then the time now is
10:54 and I 954 9:54 I did that last
time didn't I 10 9:54 and I close this
meeting members please be upstanding
whilst the chairman